italy was an interesting actor in world
war one because it was one of the
original members of the triple alliance
so in 1882 italy becomes a member of the
triple alliance the whole reason why it
was called a triple alliance is because
it was between italy austria-hungary and
germany but despite being part of that
defensive pact that they would defend
each other if if any of these other
parties like russia were to attack them
or france were to attack them it was an
awkward alliance because italy was a
historical enemy of austria-hungary
austria-hungary had some territory
especially some territory where some
italian speakers were some italian
nationalists were interested in
recapturing or having claims on some of
that territory i've circled some of that
right over here so right from the get-go
it was an awkward alliance and even in
that first triple alliance italy got an
exception for this defensive alliance it
says we don't want to be at war with
great britain then in 1902
in italy gets into another secret or i
guess this is the first of many secret
deals with france and so if you've ever
played diplomacy this is what diplomacy
is all about you make deal with one
person but maybe in secret you're making
exceptions with other people they get
into a secret pact
secret pact
with france where italy is essentially
saying look you know even though we're a
member of this triple alliance and we've
already said that we're not going to be
at war with great britain we're also
going to say that for france as well
we're we're really not in a mood to be
at war with you
so then when you fast forward to 1914
and we're now at the beginning of world
war one august germany declares you know
july austria-hungary declares war on
serbia russia begins to mobilize germany
declares war on russia and on france
italy because of this kind of
awkwardness in its triple alliance
actually decides to stay neutral
so italy stays neutral and their
justification for staying neutral is
that the triple alliance is a defensive
pact it says hey we're going to defend
each other if anyone attacks us but
they're saying that in in 1914 at the
beginning of world war one it was
austria-hungary that decided to take the
offensive it was germany that took the
offensive just based on mobilization in
russia that took the offensive against
france and and in terms of declaring war
on russia so italy says hey look this is
a defensive pact the tr the other two
members of the triple alliance they're
being they're being offensive we don't
want that means that we aren't bound to
it we're only bound to it in the event
of defense but you could imagine a lot
of it was them just trying to figure out
who's likely to win this in which
scenario are they likely to gain the
most so you fast forward to 1915
in particular april 26th
april 26th the italians are negotiating
with the allies thinking about what type
of territory they could capture
especially from austria-hungary and on
april 26 they signed the treaty of
london which at this point is a secret
treaty of london it's not broadcast to
the other members of the triple alliance
but it's an agreement with the triple on
taunt that hey look we are on your side
we are going to declare war on the
central powers imminently
and they do so
on may
in may 1915 on may 3rd they they they
back out of the triple alliance out
of
triple
alliance
out of triple alliance and then on may
may 23rd
they declare war on their historical
enemy but one of the co-signers of the
triple alliance declare war on the
austro-hungarian empire on the
austro-astro-hungarian
empire and as we'll see
this was actually italy's entering on
the one into the war on the side of the
allies against austria-hungary actually
played a major role in the eventual
downfall of the
austro-hungarians and i'll go into that
into more detail in the next video